well it's it's a thrill and an honor to
be here with you guys like frankly I'm
just so pleased this is really nice
Maxwell it's an absolute pleasure uh to
have you here today and I I want to
thank you for coming on the show because
you're one of the uncommon type of
combinations that I that I love talking
to and find you know so enlightening
which is a philosopher who's also fluent
in mathematics and I think that brings
an an interesting rigor you know to the
philosophy and and there's actually like
a really cool inter play between
philosophy and Mathematics and Science
so I think I think you gain a lot as a
philosopher the more science and math
you know and vice versa you gain a lot
as a scientist and a mathematician the
more philosophy you know well thanks
very much for your kind words um I'm
inclined to uh agree that philosophy and
formal training go uh hand in hand and
you know that it is something of a
strange historical circumstance that we
we don't think of philosophy as a very
formal discipline anymore uh you know if
if you went back a hundred years uh some
of the main there was no separation
years ago there was no distinction
between science and philosophy right
absolutely think back to the pr
prinkipia Mathematica right uh you know
uh Russell and Whitehead uh philosopher
mathematicians uh you know it was very
common back in the day and uh less so
now but you know let's hope that uh the
trend is reversing uh I I'm definitely
optimistic about this I think uh I I
increasingly find myself surrounded by a
very technical uh colleagues who also
have uh strong philosophical backgrounds
uh so uh yeah hopefully things are
changing for the
better yeah and you know it's
interesting I'm going to take the time
to ask you since you are you know a
philosopher like by by education and and
I mean no offense folks to to
philosophers whatsoever because I think
science has lost out on losing losing
philosophy and philosophy has lost out
on losing science and like the the rigor
that you know confirming your thoughts
against reality uh can have I mean do
you find that to be the case which is
that I find a lot of philosophers you
know without that grounding kind of in
in Science and Mathematics they spend a
lot of time pontificating really about
things that just amount to the to the
vague
and ambiguity of like natural language
rather than than being able to map it to
something symbolic something concrete
you
know well um so I think uh I think it
depends what kind of philosophy we're
talking about um I mean in in general I
think um the the ultimate problem is
that being a philosopher of science is
difficult because you have to be a
philosopher ER and a
scientist um and usually when when
you're training you can only do one PhD
so I mean I think to be like a proper
philosopher of science you know you
would have to be familiar with the the
history of philosophy and contemporary
philosophy of science and also uh to get
some proper training in the discipline
upon upon which you are you know
directing your Reflections um and so you
know in my case I had to do a lot of um
kind of training on my own so my my uh
most of my coursework um was in
philosophy and cognitive science and so
the the the more formal stuff that I
wield um I've had to teach myself as a
kind of side job so like when I was
doing you know my Master's and my PhD uh
in philosophy and coai I would also be
teaching myself math on the side and I
think that you know to to to to uh you
know exist effectively at these
intersections you you can't help but uh
get some multidisciplinary training and
you know I think a good philosopher of
science is necessarily A polymath in
some sense like you you you need
absolutely right and I think that's that
is what makes it that is what makes it a
kind of a rare breed right like uh you
know like one of my favorite
philosophers of of mathematics is Eric
cuel and he and he has so much great you
know content on on general relativity
and Mathematics and philosophy in
general but like you say there are these
rare these rare combinations Andor it
takes a lot of self-study you know to
develop that that's right yeah um and I
mean you know topics like the free
energy principle and active inference
are inherently multidisciplinary so it's
it's Beyond just like the philosophy and
the math uh you know what if if you're
in some sense if you're doing it well
then uh insights from every discipline
will wind up making contributions to the
way that you're thinking uh Fe
theoretically so um yeah uh but I um
this is one of the things that I love
the most about uh our intellectual
Community uh around the Fe and active
inferences the multidisciplinar the
multi-disciplinary nature of it um and
that's sort of unavoidable right um so
you know the free energy principle uh
which we'll be discussing uh today is a
an explanatory principle that prop that
its proponents at least purport applies
to uh every scale at which physical
systems
self-organize and therefore uh you know
insights from all the different
disciplines working on on all the
different kind kinds of things uh become
relevant and and the Fe then acts as a
kind of like meta theoretical
architecture to fit these claims
together U in a way that's tractable uh
from a physics and from a mathematics
perspective well one of my earliest
childhood memories is um understanding
how cartisian coordinates work when I
was uh I guess uh yeah 11 or 12 years
old uh kind of really like understanding
the mechanics of that and going like wow
like there are disciplines where there
are exact answers to the questions that
we have um and so yeah I was always uh
very into the sciences and math but I
I've also always been very interested in
the big questions um and by the time I
was done with High School uh I was I I
was either going into um uh philosophy
uh physics or film and so uh I ended up
deciding to go into philosophy and I uh
I remained a physics and math geek
throughout uh so I'm self-taught in a
lot of ways uh and yeah I ended up
specializing in philosophy and cognitive
science the philosophy of cognitive
science and uh formal approaches in
cognitive science in particular you know
when I was doing my undergrad uh the
embodied inactive embedded extended
traditions and cognitive science were
very
um and so I uh I learned some dynamical
systems theory um and I was very into
ecological psychology which is uh a
branch of psychology that attempts to
apply principles from physics to
understand action perception Loops so I
was very into all of this cluster of
ideas and um around late 2014 early 2015
I was exposed to the free energy
principle and the ideas of Carl friston
um in part uh by reading uh this this
really wonderful and by now seminal
paper of Andy Clark's called whatever
next um which was his uh famous BBS
paper where he kind of reintroduced uh
the the predictive processing framework
um and you know active inference along
with the free energy principle um so
that essentially uh combined everything
that I had ever found interesting in
some sense and I had a real kind of
conversion experience if you want to
call it that um and so uh yeah I uh I
had the pleasure and privilege of
meeting Carl In the Flesh in May
2016 um at a decision-making conference
in Montreal and uh you know you you've
spoken to Carl a few times he was uh
very typical of Carl he was very
extremely generous with his time and
friendly and
insightful um and and at the time I was
working on sociocultural Dynamics and I
was wondering whether it was apt to
apply the free energy principle to
explain this kind of you know Ensemble
Dynamics and you know Carl uh responded
uh with an affirmative answer uh and
encouraged me to uh you know take this
seriously and exchange with a few other
people um and what began was a very
extensive email correspondence that
turned into some papers uh Carl then
became PhD supervisor uh and I I spent
about yeah the better part of two years
in London uh with his group at UCL uh
learning the ins and outs of the free
energy principle um yeah and so um so I
I guess uh that's that's sort of my
story and how I met Carl uh that's
interesting you know and the the free
energy principle so um you learned about
it much earlier than than I did I wish
I'd had known about it earlier but I
didn't come across it until I guess a
couple years ago when were the first you
know the First mlst episodes that that
we did on it but I had had quite a bit
of basy and you know background um up
into that point so when I first saw it
thought wow this is It's really
ingenious you know I like I'm I'm
fascinated by it and we wanted to learn
more and so we've had we've had
Professor friston on the show a couple
of times and like you said tremendously
insightful uh you know one of the most
brilliant people I've ever spoken to
it's such a joy um to talk to him and I
think even we he's been on the show a
few times and talked about it we should
probably frame up a little bit about
what the free energy principle is you
know absolutely it'll play a big role in
our communication going forward here so
let me take a stab at it absolutely
you're the expert like I like well
you're usually really good at
summarizing well you know what
fascinates me about it I think is and I
want to get to the the Crux of this this
beautiful statement that was made about
it being the ultimate exist ential
question right because usually we think
um what does what does a life form or a
thing even for that matter what does it
have to do to survive right like this is
kind of the emphasis of you know are you
fit in the darwinian sense you know what
kind of Fitness does it take to survive
but this the free energy principle
completely inverts that and it says okay
if things exist if things survive what
must they do right and it turns it on
the head in this way which is let's
assume that they is a thing you know and
it and it continues to survive it
continues to exist just by knowing that
what must it do you know what what
Dynamics what Behavior must it have is
that a fair Framing and and what is what
are those behaviors that things that
exist must do um so uh yeah no I think
uh the way that you uh describe things
is uh accurate and an insightful way of
putting things uh the free energy
principle
is not just a u basically a theory uh
According to which uh things that exist
uh must be doing this or that uh as in
it's not it's not trying to um to tell
you uh here's something that things do
in order to exist what it's what it's
telling you is we we observe that things
exist in the sense that uh there are uh
there are umst systems or uh particles
or things uh that can be reliably
reidentified that are uh separated from
but coupled to their environment and
given that we observe these things that
exist uh what must be true of them so
it's a kind of inversion of the
explanation moving to like a kind of a
first principles account of what what
what must necessarily be the case uh if
you exist and essentially what the free
energy principle tells you is that if
you exist in the sense that you are uh
separate from but coupled to an
embedding environment then it will look
as if you're tracking the statistical
structure of your environment or more
precisely it'll look as if the states or
paths that are internal to uh a given to
your boundary of a given thing track
things that are external to that
boundary um so in some sense it it
explains why U or it Prov provides a a
principle allowing us to uh yeah explain
why uh it it looks as if everything that
exists is uh yeah tracking or
representing depending on how you want
to think about it uh features that are
external to it um and this this tracking
or representing relation is um it is
rather weak in some sense but we're not
talking about like necessarily
contentful representations little images
in my head what we're talking about is
uh something I think more fundamental or
existential so for example um I can see
from uh your your camera uh feed that
you're wearing a uh a button shirt uh
that tells me something about your
environment uh so I I can read off you
from the fact that you know you're
wearing a button shirt that you're
probably not in the Arctic somewhere I
mean I can see your background also that
that's kind of cheating uh the basically
we um we can read off anything uh
properties of its in of its embedding
environment by virtue of the fact that
it exists right right so yeah and there
I think there's an interesting point in
there which is that it isn't this exact
one toone correspondence and I mean
really how could it be right like how
could a how could say a subset of the
system precisely represent the entire
system but instead in a sense it's
representing an abstraction ABS system
you know and and I mean I think there
are even good energetic arguments why
that would be the case because you know
you since you can't maintain total
information you maintain an abstraction
of it you maintain enough in order that
you can predict and track you know
behaviors because you exist you must
continue to exist but you don't require
complete information only sufficient
sufficient tracking is absolutely yeah
heuristically you can think of the the
free energy principle and this is
metaphorical of course but as a a map of
that part of the territory that behaves
like a map so uh it is uh a scientific
uh principle that we can use to
construct models of systems that appear
as if they are in turn modeling or
tracking aspects of their environment um
and I think thinking about modeling for
a second is useful here so if you had a
one one Scale map is it borz who who uh
presents that in a in a story at some
point yeah I think so yeah so a onetoone
scale map would be completely useless
right uh I mean just imagine the
quantity of paper that you would need to
have a map of say la right a onet to one
Scale map of La it wouldn't be useful in
the generation of uh you know your
actions uh so the map is necessarily
simpler than the territory um but that's
okay in some sense right because the
implication of that is that using the
map you're going to encounter errors
you're going to generate errors but uh
in the active inference and the free
energy principle approach those errors
are the relevant signal basically so all
all you have to do is have a good enough
map and act in such a way that you are
informed by what your map contains in
terms of information um and to in real
time course correct based on the errors
that you're generating um so it's the
these errors in the kind of
oversimplified character of the model
are features rather than bugs uh you you
would need that in order to have a
signal at all in some sense yeah there
and there there is this iterative nature
to it that I think is is sometimes
forgotten because uh you know there are
these two components in the free energy
principle um one is Fidelity how
accurately does it kind of map to uh the
environment like so so if you if you
think of the the the entity that's
surviving the thing that's surviving you
know it has to have a model of the
environment has to be have some degree
of fidelity because if it doesn't it's
not accurate enough to maintain its
survival but at the same time it also
has to have adaptability right because
the information is never complete
there's always new uh you know
phenomenon occurring to it the the
environment is changing or whatever so
the model has to maintain a degree of
flexibility right and that's what this
this kind of entropy term in there is
it's saying precisely um you know you
need to maintain a certain amount of
entropy because that is a form of
flexibility is that correct I mean
that's absolutely correct and you can
think of the entropy in a a few
different ways um and it the the entropy
term in previous discussions with Carl
friston you have highlighted its
technical importance um I mean basically
what we are uh what we're trying to do
when we minimize free
energy is to uh increase the predictive
accuracy uh of our model um so that is
uh to have a model that uh generates
predictions that are as close as
possible to the real data that I'm
ingesting um but the free energy
principle uh allows us to in a in a
principled manner um penalize the
complexity of the model right because
you don't just want an arbitrary
explanation as you know you can
construct an arbitrary uh explanation
for for any uh data set and uh you know
well can even be deleterious if it's you
have in if you have incomplete
information and you model it too
accurately accurately in a loose sense
then actually you're you're just you're
you're memorizing uh spurious
information that doesn't generalize
absolutely yeah absolutely and so um the
free energy principle uh when you're
when you're applying it and you're
saying that uh systems that exist
minimize this this quantity variational
free energy uh the the variational free
energy can be decomposed uh roughly
speaking into predictive accuracy minus
complexity and so what you're doing is
you're you're penalizing your gains in
predictive accuracy against uh the the
the complexity cost of your model
basically penalizing every new degree of
Freedom that you need to introduce into
your model to explain the data so in
some sense uh the free energy principle
uh is sort of like um you can think of
it as um kind of like uh statistical
predictive accuracy
uh but also aam's razor right right
right so yeah
the no no it it makes sense I mean and
and that's it's this interesting balance
and the free energy principle encodes
that balance and I guess the simplest
the simplest way possible this this is a
sense in which the free free energy
principle applies to itself because it's
right it's almost the simplest
formulation of that of that balance
right yeah I mean um there all sorts of
ways to control for complexity that have
been introduced in machine learning um
but uh those all uh might seem ad hoc in
some sense what we try to do is to build
in this complexity control uh right into
the objective function that that we're
using right so it's it's at the core of
the architectures that rather than just
use
reward uh which you could probably cast
in terms of like predictive accuracy so
I think we we have one more foundational
concept that I'd like to kind of get on
the table and that is just the concept
of a thing you know because because a
thing the idea of a thing is is defined
in a very certain way in the context of
the the free energy principle and it's
all about this this marov blanket and
and we we've talked about Mark on
blankets a few times on the show they
tend to be confusing you know I I tend
to I I almost visualize them usually as
uh cells like in in the human body so
like you know you have a cell and it has
stuff inside and then it has the cell
membrane and then there's the stuff
outside which is kind of the environment
and that membrane in a sense is the
marov blank it's the set of stuff and
States between you know what's inside
and outside but can you talk a bit about
you know why marov blankets are
important what they are you know how
they're defined um and maybe some of the
edge cases like does an eternal flame
have a marov blanket why or why not
that's those that's a great set of
questions um
so uh you can think of the free energy
Principle as um a the same kind of thing
as the principle of least action uh in
the sense that it's it's a principle
that allows you to write down uh
mechanical theories or mechanics right
uh so uh classical mechanics has the
principle of least action um and the
principle of least action is basically a
way of uh specifying the uh the the
conservation laws that we want to see
our systems conform to in particular the
the balance of the potential in kinetic
energies uh are zero and uh the real
trajectory of systems physical systems
are those for which that balance uh
holds and they they are maybe I'll just
quickly interject here it's not so much
that we want them to conform to that
it's just that they do yeah like and
that and that's actually key to the free
energy principle too because it's it's
not like it's not like we want things to
obey the free energy principle it's they
must obey the free energy principle if
if they you know exist right absolutely
I was speaking in in the manner of a
mathematician oh yeah no totally totally
get it I just wanted to point this out
to our readers is that because as we go
along like you are almost these are
principles that in the case of classical
mechanics just are they're just the way
things behave right and in the case of
the free energy principle if you survive
if you exist you're inexorably drawn to
this set of Dynamics to the set of
mechanics otherwise you don't exist well
to get technical for a second I think
there are two issues uh that that are
both striking uh and that speak to what
you just said so uh things like the
principle of least action and the free
energy principle and the principle of
Maximum entropy uh they are in some
sense true aiori or mathematically they
are mathematical truths so you wouldn't
try to falsify the principle of of least
action empirically any more than you
would say uh try to falsify calculus or
probability Theory by coming up with an
empirical counter example so there's a
sense in which like the the truth of
these statements is robust and
mathematical um having said that it is a
striking empirical fact that the
physical Universe does in fact seem to
conform to these mathematical
regularities so it's sort of a onew
punch uh in some sense and right right
it's the unreasonable effectiveness of
absolutely yeah uh and and it's getting
even more unreasonable now with the the
free energy principle coming into play
um so the way I like to think about the
free energy principle is uh like I was
saying as introducing a new family of
mechanical theories or mechanics so uh
you have classical mechanics uh which
follows from the principle of least
action um and you have quantum mechanics
and you have statistical mechanics um so
basically the idea behind the free
energy principle is let's get the rest
of physics working in the background so
you get you get your classical
statistical and quantum mechanics
working with all of those uh yeah all of
that mechanics is in play and then you
ask a simple question what does it mean
to be a thing in this context I.E what
could it possibly mean to uh
reidentifying that question lead to a
basian mechanics uh so basian mechanics
is a physics um but it's a it's a
physics for the that that kind of dually
constrains uh the system itself the
physical system and the beliefs that the
system encodes about the things to which
it's coupled right and that I think is
really the key uh for that kind of
underwrites this whole construction uh
this is also what makes it unique among
other
uh you know candidates in the cognitive
sciences and the biosciences uh it's
that it is connecting the thermodynamic
entropy of the states the system is made
of to the information entropy of the
beliefs the probabilistic beliefs that
those States encode so the free energy
principle is all about this hinge
between the two and the equations of
motion that you write down using the
free energy principle are constrained in
both of these spaces
and that I think is absolutely the key
to understanding what's going on here
like the the the system trajectories
that you get uh when you're writing uh
when you're writing down an Fe theoretic
uh model uh of the system that you're
considering it is constrained both by
the the physics and thermodynamics of
the system and by the physics of the
representations if you will uh that the
system is entertaining about the rest of
the universe in some sense um and I
think it's it's not without precedence
in the sense that for example on
statistical mechanics you know back back
when we're deriving boltzman's
distribution and there were questions
about are these particles do they behave
as if they're identical or if they have
the same attributes are they are they
are they the same particle and the same
thing with um poly exclusion you know it
applies to some particles and not others
so there those are examples of where a
statistical um calculation a statistical
property does map to the actual
underlying physics you know that that's
happening as well this is almost a a big
step up from that it's like you know
it's it's a generalization um to a much
richer set of um I don't want to say
conservation laws but a much richer set
of these uh flow laws you know
absolutely dnamic that's exactly the
right way to think about it um in fact
it what's transpired over the last few
years is that really you can think of
the free energy Principle as a kind of
generalization of the second law
thermodynamics to open
systems um so you know the kind of
universality uh that the second law uh
has with respect to closed systems uh
the free energy principle has with
respect to systems that are far from
equilibrium and as Carl has you know
pointed out the maral blanket is
precisely the apparatus that allows you
to move from the equilibrium to the
non-equilibrium regime in the sense that
you are now specifying the interface
through which the system is coupling to
its environment or the particle so the
word system is a bit
ambiguous usually um you know because we
could mean you know the whole in agent
environment system or we could mean uh
the specific kind of compartments that
that we're considering as agents um yeah
so so the uh you can think of the the
free energy Principle as applying to um
systems that are not at equilibrium and
as giving you the Dynamics of like
particles within the overall system if
there exist particles in the system if
there are these things that you can poke
and re-identify uh over time then the
free energy principle will basically
tell you how they behave on
average yeah and it's it's interesting
because almost the marov blanket really
provides a concept of stability because
when I think about equilibrium right
when when um you know the thermodynamic
kind of equilibrium what comes to mind
at least visually to me is things that
are kind of unchanging and and just kind
of quiescent and they're just sitting
there like a goo you know that's kind of
all thermally stabilized and never never
moving around but that's the point the
key point there is stability like it's a
it's a stable sort of unchanging system
and what the marov blanket gives you is
a way of defining a property that's
stable about the system and yet the
system as a whole may be far from stable
it may be influx and moving around all
the time and jiggling it's the Eternal
Flame where the boundary is you know
kind of changing all the time but
there's this property that you can map
from from time to time that that's still
there and so it's the stable um the
stable blanket even though it may have a
different form it's still got a boundary
between some stuff that's inside and
outside that's identifiable you know
from frame to frame if you will yeah and
I I I i' I'd go even further and say
that it's the self-identical pattern
that you see at all scales of
self-organization uh so it's got this
kind of fractal quality to it where uh
you know the it's blankets of blankets
of blankets of blankets uh so I mean you
can think of the brain for example uh so
the brain has this nice maral blanketed
structure uh at several different scales
so you can start with neurons um and
neurons have their own uh marov blankets
that yeah they and cell membrane yeah
precisely uh and it's probably the most
obvious but you can go downwards in
scales and upwards in scales and what
you recover uh are uh you know similarly
marov blanketed structures uh you know
from uh the uh the from the voltage ated
channels uh on a cell membrane to
dendrites uh to the you know
arborescences that that form up to the
the the uh the neurons Soma uh and then
you know uh you could go the other
direction too right from uh neurons to
canonical micro circuits uh to uh more
specialized brain regions to brain
networks and so on all of these things
are things they can be reliably
reidentified with their own kind of uh
you know uh properties and features and
connectivity to other things um and they
all have this same pattern uh that
repeats uh and so it it really is yeah
so and and I think anybody can see that
pattern you know I mean look around we
got we have trees and they have
boundaries and you know you even higher
in scale you have planets and and
galaxies and but at the same time if you
if you dig down into it and you try to
really precise
Define it then it it slips away it's
like if I zoom into the surface of my
skin you know fine enough well it's no
longer a surface it's this ragged thing
with cell membranes and then the cell
membranes are molecules with tons of
space you know in between them and heck
atoms you know are mostly empty right
like there's this this weird you know
vagueness and difficulty in defining you
know boundaries so they're not sharp
like how's the concept of of a Markov
blanket how does it evolve to that kind
of fuzziness or or this this great set
of questions your questions are so on
point frankly uh this is uh so um I
would say
the the first thing to say is that so
this is sort of Mind physics or brain
physics if you want to think about it
like that and um one Hallmark of
explanation in physics is simplification
or uh you know you might say
oversimplification um so I I'm sure um a
biologist reading a paper on the free
energy principle might look at this and
go but you know this is way too
oversimplified where is the biological
detail um I think physicists also do
this to physical phenomena right like
that's that's sort of the joke a
physicist would respond yeah but we do
that to physics as well right like it's
uh so yeah there is a deliberate
idealization going on uh if you define
this maral blanket strictly as the the
set of degrees of freedom that render
some in inside independent of the
outside right so if conditioned on the
blanket States you can speak of
statistical Independence between the
inside and the outside well um that that
is too strict to describe most physical
systems right uh so I assume uh you
myself and our listeners we all had a
bit of coffee this morning we've all
used the washroom uh so there's clearly
a kind of permeabil exactly there's
clearly a kind of permeability at play
um and so uh we we know that there is
material turnover in most of the kinds
of systems that we find interesting
especially those that self-organize far
from equilibrium so the markall blanket
is
necessarily um an
idealization um having said that um
there are good reasons to think and we
have some results coming out uh later
this year uh a lot of them are due to
our senior mathematician Dalton Shak
dadel who is an absolute Dynamo um so
yeah I've seen I've seen some of his
papers yeah it's it's very impressive
stuff he he's been working on um weak or
fuzzy blankets uh in precisely this
context so the the idea is uh can we uh
get really rigorous about the uh
mathematics of approximate marov
blankets or fuzzy marov blankets um and
the idea in a lot of his work is to
construct this this quantity called the
blanket index uh to gloss over some of
the technical details just
in the interest of our uh our audience
uh basically uh there in if you consider
a given dynamical system there exists a
Marco blanket in that system if a
specific inner product is equal to zero
uh so in particular this is the the
Hessian of the and the the solenoidal
flow the product of those two things
being zero but it it basically is a way
of um quantifying the the force or the
curvature uh that a system is subject to
uh and yeah if if the entries in this in
product are zero then there is a strict
maral blanket but there's a way of
constructing um an index or a measure
such that you can accumulate the
non-zero entries um and basically
quantify how far from perfect blanketed
n a system finds itself um and so uh
yeah this blanket index has a number of
interesting prop properties um one of
which is that it it it uh tends to zero
as systems increase in size H so under
what kind of assumption so it TS um it's
very very very general um so I locality
assumption or something you get the
locality stuff from from the background
right so you get the rest of mechanics
going right so okay okay so then you
already have like you know relativity in
the background and you have statistical
mechanics and all that so yeah uh you do
get uh this kind of nice locality so
that's interesting so in in a universe
like ours that has the the basic physics
that that a universe like ours has as
the scale of a system gets larger and
larger you you generate marot blankets
surely with a probability one yeah
absolutely fascinating uh and you know
most of the systems that we consider in
physics are large in the appropriate
sense right uh so think about how many
molecules are in in a drop of water
right it's 10 to the 26 right some some
something times avagadro's number by
itself is 10 to the 23rd yeah 10 to the
23 sorry yeah so that's just for a
single drop of water now if you consider
the brain the brain has like something
on the order of 100 150 billion neurons
uh Each of which make thousands of
connections if each of those connections
can encode a parameter then you're
talking about like a very large system
right we're we're way way way Beyond
like you know 20 50 1,000 different
states that that are coupled together
we're talking about like billions and
trillions of different states so there's
reason to think that just due to the
physics of the
situation uh most relevant things that
we might want to consider will have
Markov blankets um and uh I mean so
Dalton is going to be releasing a few
papers having to do with large
fluctuation theorems okay this let's
pause for a minute and appreciate this
because this to me is a
fascinating a fascinating result so okay
so we start from the point of a marov
blanket is kind of this intuitive
concept right like it's you know a
boundary and and that sort of thing but
there's no reason to believe that
they're inevitable and I'm finding it
fascinating fting that there's that
there's this work right that says that
as a scale incre so we have a measure of
blankness it's kind of between zero and
one zero has a a blanket one doesn't
okay and and yet as the scale of the
system gets larger and larger blanket
approaches you know zero you you get
blankets um no matter what and in a
sense there's a sense in which that's
recapitulating what we see if we just
look around like everybody out there
listening look around yourself and
you're going to see blanket it's all
over the place you're going to see
things and those things have have
boundaries right but it's it's
remarkable right that that there's a
mathematical proof that that's
inevitable um in this sense isn't it
well I I I think it's remarkable in part
because we have approached uh the
question of self-organization and
emergence from a a false starting point
uh so I I've been going around saying
recently Aristotle was wrong that's
that's sort of philosophical start well
the whole is much less than the sum of
its parts it turns out um so uh yeah
there there are a bunch of things to
unpack from that well the first is that
um what makes you the kind of thing that
you are is the sparsity of your coupling
to the rest of the world right if you
think of a gas right everything is
coupled to everything else then it's
just this fuzz and it's all one system
and there's there's no you can't really
identify particles within the system
uh particles or things are defined by
their sparse connections to everything
else so I am in some sense what I am not
uh or I can be defined in terms of what
I'm not connected to as opposed to what
I am connected to I mean if you were to
create like a giant adjacency Matrix for
the entire universe most of it would be
empty right no I get what you're saying
the whole the hole is less than some of
the parts which is there's more if you
if you get rid of the parts you have you
have less right and but but there's more
um the uh so think of an engine right
like an engine functions as an organized
whole uh because you're constraining its
parts to behave in very specific ways so
like you know if you think of an engine
more specifically like a a petrol engine
um well the the mechanical effect of the
engine you get by you know moving these
pistons in a specific you know Direction
up and down and the best way to wreck
your engine is to introduce new degrees
of freedom into it right I would not
want to introduce new degrees of freedom
into the Pistons it's a that's a great
way to just tear your engine apart and I
would uh submit to you that this is uh
you know an accurate way of thinking
about all self-organization we exist as
holes because our parts are constrained
to behave in very specific ways so it's
not merely that I am what I am because I
I am not what I am not
is a nice topology uh it's that the what
makes me what I am is the way that I
remove degrees of freedom from my parts
such that they conspire to create you
know to generate me as an overall
pattern uh so I mean it's it's
counterintuitive from the perspective
that we inherited from you know a
traditional Aristotelian metaphysics but
um I mean uh yeah it's it's so exciting
I mean h i don't know I don't know why I
get excited but to me it's it's really
excited and this I mean so this is work
that's coming out of verses correct
that's right yeah that's right coming
out of I would say uh coming out of uh
Carl friston's group more generally and
let's not forget you know Carl uh
proposed the free energy principle in
the middle of the 200000
knots um and so yeah uh but definitely
this is uh the the the PowerHouse behind
uh versus AI Technologies so yeah let's
talk about that for a minute because um
we generally don't talk about you know
companies on the show but this to me
this is an exception because it's it's
fascinating what you guys are doing
thank you and um so versus versus
technology is trying to
operationalize this understanding really
and as as technology and I guess and I
I'm super excited by what we've been
talking about conceptually but tell me
why should they inate care like what
does this what does this fascinating you
know view of philosophy and and
Mathematics and the relationship to
really I I think it's really about
understanding complex systems in in a
new way and new mechanics of complex
systems what does that mean for us what
does it mean
technologically well thank you for your
excellent question um so I think one of
the things that we want to do versus is
to uh apply active inference to
artificial intelligence so active
inference is basically the kind of
machine learning that follows from
adopting the free energy Principle as
your kind of core method our contention
at versus is that active inference will
be to the 2020s what reinforcement
learning was to the 2010s effectively so
uh it's going to be we think the way of
doing uh machine learning uh the ethical
scalable most efficient way of doing
machine
learning um and there are a lot of
different um aspects to that um so uh
one of the main differences between uh
artificial intelligence built on the
principles of active inference and more
traditional approaches is that we start
um from an explicit generative model
socalled um so we talked about the marov
blanket um the generative model is
another core piece of the free energy
principle uh puzzle or uh constellation
if you will and the the generative model
is basically um a a statistical
description of the dependency relations
within the system that you're
considering um so when we're talking
about marov blankets actually what we're
saying is the generative model of the
system contains a marov blanket right so
all of these dependency relations that
we're writing down uh like once you do
write them down you get this nice
spareness structure where some parts of
the system do not affect other parts of
the system um and so yeah uh this this
generative model um is is really key to
the doing of the free energy principle
um and so uh yeah what we do in active
inference is write down generative
models explicitly labeled generative
models that then allow us to uh you know
perform inference uh they allow us to do
that because the uh variational free
energy that we were discussing earlier
um basically the the uh the gradients of
the free energy that you're following
they come from this generative model
basically um right so uh yeah the the
model itself is this explicitly labeled
structure and this is where you get like
a huge
explainability uh Advantage we we
actually have a paper that uh came out
uh on designing art artificial
intelligence explainable artificial
intelligence using active inference and
yeah what what you get just immediately
from flipping to an active inference
framework is a way to write down uh yeah
generative model such that it is
explicitly labeled and thereby auditable
uh by human users and stakeholders uh so
you don't have this unlabeled you know
trillion parameter net as it were right
what you have instead is uh yeah a a
model that explicitly represents all of
the different factors in the situation
that you want to control so let me dig
into this let me dig into this a little
bit um
so and I because I'm curious there's a
connection here to some some work I used
to do a long time ago so writing down
generative models my experience has been
at least is uh it's it's actually
relatively easy to do that so for
example a long time ago um I was
contracted to do some work on mad cow
disease so we could try and figure out
what interventions to do to reduce right
the spread of mad cow disease and it was
pretty pretty easy to uh learn about the
uh the food system the supply chain the
food system to model you know the
processing of um of cattle and that sort
of thing and write down a large
simulator so this would be a generative
model can sit there and can generate
trajectories through the space right
like we knew we could do that we
couldn't tell you anything about the
large scale kind of thermodynamics of
the system or or anything right we could
write down this generative model though
and then using um you know various
sampling and techniques like that we
could then um uh compute statistics from
it try out interventions see which of
those had had kind of a beneficial
effect but that was all ad hoc you know
architecture that we we designed and and
produced by ourselves if I'm
understanding you correctly um what
you're doing is producing a technology
that one um formalizes that much more
and applies the free energy principle I
think to help guide like the sampling
and the optimization and you know really
just the effective use of these kind of
generative you know simulations and
models um is that close to what you're
talking about that's right um so I mean
you can why use active inference it is
demonstra the most efficient machine
learning technique so it's sort of like
a you know a caros cycle analysis but
for for an engine but for AI uh in
particular uh what the free energy
principle uh allows us to formalize uh
is the thermodynamics of information
writing onto the boundary um so uh in in
some of the newer work uh on the quantum
information theoretic formulation of the
free energy principle uh which we don't
necessarily have to get into it in
detail but uh there are these kind of
new uh scale-free extensions to the free
energy principle that have been
developed uh that appeal to the tools
that have been developed on in quantum
mechanics right so the theory of very
small fast things but Quantum
information Theory uh so the kind of
information theory that gets augmented
to handle things like probability
amplitudes which are the uh the roots of
probability densities and so you can get
your wave equations moving in place and
all that so the uh that formulation of
the free energy principle allows us to
formulate uh the computations carried
out by a system in terms of like a per
bit read and write cost so there's a
there's a there's a sense in which like
you're you're bringing it down to the
like to the the bare kind of you know
machine elements of the of your
computations and your you're writing
things down in a way that is
demonstrably the most efficient way of
doing it so if you if you set up you
know some simulation system using active
inference you are uh and this kind of
brings the conversation full circle in
some sense you are generating a model
that is as predictively accurate as
possible but also that expends as little
energy as possible due to this you know
controlling for the uh complexity of the
model so there yeah we we have this
this pre-print uh up that we'll be
revising soon um called the map
territory fallacy fallacy which is
precisely about the kind of uh canonical
nature of uh FP theoretic modeling uh
yeah the you know the one of the reasons
why the FP is optimal um is that it's
it's another way of writing down James's
maximum entropy principle
so for our audience uh the maximum
entropy principle uh you can think about
it from from the point of view of
statistics and also from the point of
view of statistical mechanics from the
point of view of statistical ma
mechanics the maximum entropy principle
is the principle According to which
things
dissipate um so uh from from the point
of view of Statistics it's the principle
According to which give me a data set uh
and a set of models from which I might
have sampled that data set the it says
the model with the highest entropy is
most likely to be the uh the real model
from which you sampled so that's a way
of kind of saying like what is a maximum
entropy probability density it's a flat
density right and so basically a maximum
entropy probability density encodes no
information because all of the outcomes
are equally probable and in some sense
what razor would tell you is that like
you would want your model to be as flat
as possible Right you want to build in
as spread out as possible exactly you
want to build in as few uh assumptions
as possible into your model this brings
it back to the whole keeping your
options open thing that you were saying
uh you were discussing earlier you know
if you're thinking of a probability
density over different courses of action
uh unless you're really sure that you
want to do this you probably want to
keep things uh as non-committal as
possible and keep your options open um
so the just to back up then the free
energy principle is a is a way of
writing down uh the principle of Maximum
entropy they are effectively the same
thing uh you can move from the one to
the other and we know that the principle
of Maximum entropy is is is the
principle of parsimonious explanation in
some sense right so if the FP and
maximum entropy are the same principle
then all of the epistemic virtues that
acred to maximum entropy also carry over
to the Fe and therefore uh yeah a a a
free energy principle theoretic model of
the belief updating of a particle can be
shown to be the optimal Dynamic systems
model for the whole system that you're
considering like there there is a kind
of
canonicity uh what we're calling Jan's
optimality that yeah the basically the
FP it allows you to write down the best
model that you could for your the system
that you're considering given your
current state of knowledge in that
system it's just the optimal way of
writing that down full stop uh so that's
why we you know care about active
Insurance yeah it might be useful to to
give you know some examples of um of you
know maximum entropy distributions to
understand so for example if you have a
data set um and and let's just suppose
it's continuous you know data and it's
and it's posit POS only so I know that
it's continuous data it's positive only
and I know that it has a particular mean
you know um then the the distribution
that has the maximum entropy under those
examples is an exponential distribution
right like it's it's sort of spread out
as much as possible um and yet it has a
particular particular mean and and and
for example if we go to the case of it
can be a real number anywhere between
minus and infinity and infinity and it
has a mean but it also has a finite
variance then you wind up with the Gan
you know distribution as being you know
the maximum so it's really it's it's a
distribution that captures what you know
about the system I.E the constraints
right and yet is as spread out as it's
possible to be while satisfying those
constraints right yeah absolutely and
and you know I hope our audience is able
to kind of see the pattern that's
starting to form here you know know uh
like all of these connections are
non-accidental right so the the Feb is
all about balancing your predictive
accuracy and your complexity so all
these things are kind of connected at a
deep level uh and yeah I mean maybe the
audience also can see why we're so
excited about this like this is highly
non-trivial well and and and I don't
know if this is crazy or not but it it
actually even seems to have implications
for uh fairness of of models because so
for for example um suppose I'm trying to
train a model that does anything of of
human interest you know
diagnose uh or prescribe Medical
Treatments or you know give out give out
loans or or that sort of thing and and
we need to train it on some type of of
data whether it's a generative model
that we calculate or um data that we
actually observe well we want we want
the system we want the machine to learn
only what's relevant for that particular
task and like nothing else you know we
don't want to to learn kind of
extraneous things so for example if it's
deciding to hand out medical diagnosis
we want it to be based solely upon the
uh medical attributes that are in in the
you know the data set and not some spous
you know correlation to like a the
geography or you know where where you
came from or or um the letters in your
name you know of your file or anything
like that and so in a sense um what
maximum entropy helps you to do is force
out that stuff because that stuff if
it's not useful for the actual
prediction it'll get you know ironed out
because it'll get smoothed out by the
demand of Maximum entropy that's right
and and that brings us back to
spareness
right how so tell me Well in the sense
that um you know this this even has to
do with like situation or task
definition uh like situations are spar
uh they're not all not everything is
connected to everything not everything
is relevant to everything else uh so
there's even like a kind of it's really
a kind of
meta methodology because you you can
even define specific situations in terms
of their spareness and then you know
yeah the so um so it sound it sounds
great but I'm always the Eternal skeptic
because I know a lot of this type of
computation you know the the generative
starting with a generative model all
doing inference on it just
computationally is so difficult like
what what is the magic that versus is
found and and how are you so sure that
uh how are you so confident it's going
to work great question um so I mean in
particular one of the big questions that
uh plagues generative modelbased methods
is where do your priors come from right
so what is the structure of your model
what what are the parameters that you're
using what's the relevant State space
all of that uh is often I mean you often
you have to handd design this stuff and
it's very labor intensive um so at
versus we are a uh a contextual
Computing company um so we draw
inspiration from the architecture of the
brain uh and uh basically we're
proposing a kind of General uh
standards-based solution to the problem
of where do your models where do your
priors come from um so just to uh you
know do a crash course in Neuroscience
um so we love Neuroscience here so
please do sure well so great source of
inspiration I I'm sure everyone is
familiar with the idea that the brain
has a layered or hierarchical structure
um so it's not the case that the brain
is just a soup of connections where
everything connects to everything else
um no to the contrary there is there are
very regular structured patterns of
connectivity uh in the brain um okay
again this takes us back to the theme of
spareness right uh like the to say that
the brain has a hierarchical
organization is to say that it evinces a
specific very special kind of spareness
where connections uh are directed in
specific ways where you're you're
connected to layers immediately above
and below you but nothing beyond that um
so we've spoken in the past to to Jeff
Hawkins like is this related at all to
the concepts of cortical columns and
like the way in which they're connected
like it almost has these you know
components that are reused and and put
in terms of different layers uh yeah uh
that and not all the layers speak to
each other um from a uh an active
inference perspective this layered or uh
level uh level involving structure has a
specific purpose um so what each level
is doing is providing priors uh or
expectations to the level below and
receiving context from the level
above and uh what each layer is doing in
turn is shuffling prediction errors to
the to the uh level above and receiving
prediction ER errors from the the level
uh below um so what what you have is
basically a a set of layers that
contextualize each other and the way
that each layer contextualizes the next
one is essentially course
graining right so uh there's some fast
uh fast small scale activity uh that
lower levels are tracking closer to the
sensory end and what each successive
layer is doing is finding basically the
the uh set of hidden States or latent
States uh that explain variance in the
data that it's receiving and and so on
uh in this kind of hierarchical fashion
um so the the brain is not one
monolithic system rather uh each layer
of the brain is specialized in encoding
specific features of the situation
pitched at a specific scale and it
functions by kind of providing context
so we like to say that the brain is an
organ of context effectively where uh
really what it embodies is successive
layers of context that are each course
graining each other in this kind of
fashion so I know I I know our neural
network fans out there in the audience
are going to they're they're going to be
hearing that that's just what a neural
network is like it has kind of layers
you know they're connected what's what's
different about just any other you know
kind of neural network architecture if
you will so what what we're proposing is
an infrastructure project in some sense
uh we have uh we're working with the uh
itle e um in the US and so when I say we
um vers is that has a sister uh
organization a nonprofit called the
spatial web Foundation which was uh to
whom we gifted uh the the first massive
chunk of research that came out of our
group um and what we are developing with
the spatial web Foundation is a St is a
set of public standards uh that people
can use to build out uh basically shared
knowledge graphs so we're building an
ecos system where uh folks can basically
uh think of this as sort of like Wiki
data or Wikipedia But for kind of shared
contextual compute context uh so you
know obviously uh we are building this
out so we're going to be the first to
put things onto this network but what
we're trying to build is basically a
spatial web or a hypers spatial web that
kind of in some sense reflects the
structure the kind of graph
structure um of the the various kinds of
situations that humans uh deal I got it
so it's so it's really an application of
of interesting so it's an it's an
application of the free energy principle
at multiple scales absolutely not okay
okay so my mind was going in the wrong
direction here which is I was going to
like the scale of of uh you know the
individual thing and and and how it does
its its modeling its compute but this is
this is more than that this is well it
is that you're absolutely correct but
it's more than that it's it's that it's
and it's actually like a
multiscale I guess arbitrarily nested
really uh framework for communication
across absolutely not not even it's it's
more than a mesh it's um what's the
right word for it's a hypergraph I guess
it's it's a hyperspace hypers we we call
this the you know the the name of the
protocol that we've developed uh for
modeling is called the hyperspatial
modeling language hsml it it's it's
meant as a an homage and a nod to uh H
HTML and uh what we have I hope it
doesn't use the same syntax
please no no it won't um well uh what
we've also built is a transaction
protocol and a querying language that
that live within the hyperspace so
so-called the hyperspace transaction
protocol
hstp and the hyperspace hypers SP
querying language
hsql um and so yeah what what we are
basically in the business of doing is on
the one hand building out these
graphical models uh of knowledge
basically of the knowledge that is
involved in specific tasks domains and
situations uh and then we've developed
methods to take these uh knowledge
graphs and to flip them into graphical
models of
inference uh so that's really that's
that's kind of where the the the secret
sauce and the magic happens is that this
is a two-step process and the overall
versus technology stack combines uh
active inference-based AI with explicit
generative models on the one hand and
this kind of nested hyperspatial
representation of the problems uh to be
solved on the other uh and the the
Technologies uh kind of are uh married
uh through the their kind of Reliance on
um on graphical techniques basically so
it's it's knowledge graphs meets graphic
iCal inference in a nutshell um yeah and
um we uh we really are committed to
developing these in terms of uh you know
open publicly available
standards uh you know there's a lot of
as I'm sure you're acutely aware there's
a lot of um you know hype and
atory uh you know
dorismond way there there seems to be
one call for you know government
oversight which is interesting but comes
with its lot of limitations for example
governments are limited to their
jurisdictions uh and so you know you
can't uh you can't coordinate an
International Community of research and
development in R&D merely through uh
National
regulation uh so that's limited on on
the other hand you have you know uh
markets uh and companies that want to uh
you know solve these issues in house uh
they are maybe faster and more flexible
but there is this necessity of you know
how do you how do you constrain the
activities of Corporations in such a way
that we develop these Technologies uh
responsibly ethically transparently in a
manner that's Audible and that's uh you
know acutely aware of and sensitive to
the potential harms that might be caused
by these Technologies so what we are uh
proposing is a kind of third path a
middle way not to say that we shouldn't
pursue you know a private development of
these Technologies and regulation I
think this is all uh you know a great
idea uh there's some interesting uh
legislation coming out of the EU uh the
AI act that everyone is talking about
that I think are interesting paths
forward but a to really um consolidate
the International Community around these
Technologies we have proposed a
standards based approach um and the the
i e group uh where the standards uh will
be housed uh is an open group uh folks
from anywhere can join uh we have some
uh pretty high-profile corporate
Partners but the idea is to build these
Technologies in a manner uh where we
avoid silos basically and where we can
kind of coordinate the entire world's
techn technological and intellectual
prowess towards solving these uh issues
so I I think the um and and yeah there
has been definitely um uh the threats of
AI the the risk of AI have been uh quite
quite heavily quite heavily discussed um
as
listen yeah well and you know I mean
recently we had a show about this and I
was uh pillar you know quite a bit in
the comments because my my role as uh
Devil's Advocate but I mean I I mean for
me personally I see the damage of of AI
happening right now I mean you know when
you have when you have kind of um let's
say social media algorithms that have
been highly engineered and optimized and
no small part by by Machine learning to
suck up everybody's attention you know
it's even before well before we get to
the the possible point of of super
intelligence you know in a general sense
um uh it's already damaging right and so
and and I personally think the path
forward are openness and transparency
and making sure that that the good guys
um uh that it's easy for them to do the
right thing and so I think I think like
approaches like what you're advocating
for the right way to go I mean for sure
going back in a bottle it isn't and um I
think you know you you said all the
right words transparency I think is is
more than just um transparency in the
decision making of stakeholders and
parties involved in the research and
development of AI Technologies in our
case it really means the transparency in
addition it means the transparency of
the models that we're using right uh so
you know one approach one approach to
training up AI systems might be uh you
know give AI uh access to extremely
curated data sets so that it it learns
only the right things you know in in
extremely like controlled settings um
there's reason to think that that won't
generalize easily another thing that you
can do is to equip your system with the
capacity to form inferences about it its
own inferences uh and to evaluate itself
with respect to you know things that we
value
so you could for instance design an AI
that had an explicit notion of like
discriminatory bias and then train it to
identify discriminatory bias in data
sets for example and you know uh you can
use active inference Technologies to
allow the system to access and report on
its own
inferences I mean it's it's even more
General than than that I think if I'm
understanding correctly because for
example you have these nodes right in
this in this um hyperspace you have the
you know you have you have all these
nodes in there and and you can learn for
example that say a particular node uh is
is racist you know like it'll it'll give
you great answers to a particular
question so long as it doesn't think you
have certain you know demographic
characteristics or or whatever and then
it gives you like you know bad answers
well then you can the network can learn
how to mitigate against that it can
learn how to you know compensate for The
Bu is like inherent in in nodes so not
just dat actual algorithms yeah exactly
and you know the algorithms that we're
using are based on explicitly labeled
generative models so these are systems
that can be audited by Third parties
right right right because everything is
labeled explicitly right so like you you
can really calculate the incidence of
this or that node on this or that part
of the inference and it gives you a kind
of tractable uh interpretable
uh you know auditable method of
constructing systems uh such that you
understand what went into the
decision-making process uh I said
earlier that my suspicion our wager is
that active inference will be to the
20120 is what uh reinforcement loaning
was to the
2010s my my gut tells me that if
legislation the legislation that that
they are uh you know writing up in the
US and in the EU uh goes through through
uh it may be that active inference will
be the only set of AI technologies that
we're allowed to use uh in the sense
that um so you know neural Nets as
they're used right now are black boxes
they're not explicitly labeled and they
are built to be black boxes like the
they they are not built they're not
designed to be interpretable the um the
kind of uh you know these kind of
privacy security
uh issues issues around confabulation
issues around you know the the
uninterpretable of these models these
are not like bugs in some sense they are
features of the approach that we're
using to design the systems uh you're
not using an explicitly labeled model
there is no way to render this tractable
post ha talk uh whereas if you start
from an an an approach that you know
it's it's explainable it does what it
says on the tin then you get around
these these uh these issues uh through
your choice of architecture in effect um
so you know I I think there's you know
tremendous ethical import to the manner
in which we're designing these systems
we care a lot about ethics at versus as
we discussed my my PhD even though most
of my Publications are in computational
uh neuroscience and kind of theoretical
biophysics you might say like my PhD is
in philosophy uh we're we have a lot of
properly trained ethicists really at the
core of this team and we take these
things really seriously uh ad versus so
there's no accident here uh and I really
think that active inference uh plus the
standards based approach uh is how
you're going to get something like
responsible scalable ethical
AI okay so and so far I'm on board with
everything everything I've heard but I
have a question for you though which is
if it's all open and and ethical and
you're trying to do the the right thing
how exactly is that profitable like what
you know what's going to keep the the
lights on it uh versus well so we have
our own in-house implementation of hsml
um so you know we uh we are providing
the standards so that anyone can build
uh a version of hsml We're providing the
kind of core
infrastructure uh for uh you know domain
registry and kind of stuff uh but we
also have you know very Advanced highly
engineered and developed versions of
these things that can actually do things
um so uh yeah uh yeah I mean uh you can
think of uh you know red hat and the
Linux Foundation as a kind of similar uh
aspirational model right so uh you know
Red Hat do generate a profit from a
commercial point of view that Linux is
still still open source the Linux
Foundation is the open source custodian
of the Linux operating system uh and yet
they are able to operate um our
contention is that our stack is
organized in a similar manner where uh
the spatial web Foundation is the
custodian of these Open Standards that
we are uh you know Distributing hoping
uh everyone will widely adopt them and
we are the more kind of hard-nosed
um kind of Architects uh who know how to
build things using these tools uh who
who for having built them know how they
they work uh and you know we are
probably at this point I mean almost
certainly the world's Premier active
inference research and development group
so uh there's a whole Powerhouse of you
know of well there's a lot of great
academic papers that that uh that come
out of there I mean you know I know Tim
and I have enjoyed I'm looking at uh you
know quite a few of them um well thank
you yeah you mentioned Dalton you know
earlier I mean you know there there's an
example of some some very refined and
and quite deep philosophically and
mathematically you know papers right
well we have basically hoovered up the
kind of core uh luminaries of the act of
inference tradition as it stands
currently I mean Carl friston himself is
our chief scientist and is is joining us
uh in an increasing capacity over the
next few years uh yeah uh so when you
combine that with you know I I'm fairly
uh well known in in the field uh we have
really scooped up like uh you know the
Lance dcosta Connor Hines Brennan kleene
ma ALB
barison there's
a it's it's it's pretty um sometimes
it's a little bit uh I guess the lunches
must be must be interesting there right
yeah absolutely uh yeah and I mean um
this was this was my dream uh you know
back back in Academia to uh have a
centralized research group with with all
of this Talent able to like work
together and yeah uh we're definitely
doing some interesting stuff and you
know at versus we are committed to uh
continuously also contributing to uh the
public domain and open scientific uh
publication as you said you know we're
we're a fairly productive research group
uh we published a few dozen papers last
year for example uh you know so we uh I
think there's a way of striking the
balance between uh contributing to an
open community of development having an
open core and this kind of thing on the
one hand um and also being able to
continue existing as a profit generating
entity on the other uh but really the I
think the the key strategy is this open
core right so like have the standards
open yeah make sure that everyone can
contribute to it like uh you know there
is a kind of selfish Dimension to it as
well because then we are able to harness
the entire power of the in the
intellectual International Community uh
you know to to build this uh stuff out I
think that yeah there there are there
are certainly some advantages we also
for instance uh maintain and contribute
to the PDP package uh which is a python
package to for uh partially observable
marov decision processes that power a
lot of the active inference technology
uh so we use that as our
core and it's uh it's on an open license
so anyone can just you know download
these packages go to the GitHub uh and
use it so we're trying to build these
Technologies such that you know everyone
can start to use them uh but we
definitely have uh you know some key uh
differentiators and I think a pretty uh
pretty unshakeable Market Advantage uh
well so so speaking of Market Advantage
let me um ask you about this question
which is uh as as you know we've had
we've had uh Professor first and on show
couple of times we talked about the free
energy principle a few times and and
there seems to be um a lot of uh what's
right way I say this you know
misunderstanding or even negative press
you know if you will not you know around
the free energy principle right like
like just kind of push back against it
as either something of of of trivial
trivial interest or you know a topology
that's that's of no value and we talked
about some of this too in our in our
intros so like what if any what do you
think the biggest misconceptions are
about the free energy principle Andor
Act of inference that that really acts
you know potentially just intellectual
barriers to the adoption of the
technology and this is your paper I
believe is you know the map fallacy
fallacy right which is this this
enduring kind of um difficulty in
understanding that A system can can
follow these Dynamics okay it can it can
it can behave as if it can behave as if
it has beliefs right about the world and
a model about the world and it can
behave in those ways um and it's okay to
point that out like it's okay to say yes
this thing is behaving as if it has
beliefs I'm not literally saying that
it's like a conscious mind you know that
has has beliefs what we're saying is
that if it continues to exist it must
have have these behaviors so that it
doesn't dissipate into equilibrium right
put your finger one of
the yeah I think that that's really
maybe the the most important confusion
that people have is they they think of
the free energy Principle as some part
of like philosophy or metaphysics but
it's not metaphysics it's just physics
it's physics physics uh it's
mathematical physics in some sense uh so
you know uh this isn't really a a
statement about the way that how how
things really are in some kind of deep
kind of philosophical sense it's about
how we can come to know them given the
kind of Mo the kinds of modeling tools
that we can deploy uh you know so it
there there is a kind of deflationary
aspect to the free energy principle uh
like it it is a way of writing down
canonical models for the Dynamics of
systems that we find interesting given
our state of knowledge about it uh it's
it's not it's not necessarily going to
tell you about the ultimate nature of
mind or something like that unless you
take a super deflationary approach and
you think that physics in at the end of
the day will be able to tell us
everything we need to know about the
mind uh so yeah what what makes do you
think that um yeah the the the the
physicist in wants to say yes the
philosopher in me wants to say there are
still a few issues that we need to sort
out
uh like uh you know where does
Consciousness come from but we're
working on it again using the free
energy principle uh I think one of the
things that makes this difficult is that
the free energy principle uh is um
ontological so it's about things but
it's not metaphysical in the sense that
it's not about like these fundamental
philosophical principles that tell you
about thingness it is a it is a theory
of
every without being a Theory of
Everything do you see what I mean um
right well I think and you hit upon this
earlier which is um I don't know if it's
the only example I but as far as I know
it's the only one I know of an example
that directly ties physics to to
inference or to you know belief updating
like this this the first example that
that that I know of so like you just
said you know it is it is a physics
principle and it just so happens to
correspond
to basy and updating that's right
absolutely yeah yeah or approximate basy
and variational stuff uh which is to say
basically the same thing um I'm I'm
being a bit cautious here because I
don't for those of you who uh in in our
audience follow me on Twitter you'll
know that I have uh to put it
diplomatically some reservations about
some of the recent literature that's
been published on the free energy
principle I think a lot of the issues
with the literature is sociological um
it's you know and it's difficult to talk
about this without seeming like you know
a bit like deprecating or negative but
like a lot of this work was uh written
especially the critical work was written
by early career
researchers uh who did not necessarily
have the
formal familiarity with the free energy
principle that might have been acquired
so I mean
look for example um I I I heard a lot
you know Circa 2007 2018
2019 you know uh people say well you
know the free energy principle can't be
true because some systems maximize some
their entropy right they they move
towards more entropic States uh now from
the from the the perspective of our
conversation that might seem nonsensical
because we've just spent like you know
about an hour and half talking about how
the free energy principle is a way to
write down maximum entropy uh but um
yeah the the the free energy principle
says something very specific right it
says that if I maximize the entropy of
my beliefs then I can keep the
thermodynamic entropy of my physical
States at Bay but these kind of
sophisticated kind of hinge statements
are not necessarily fully appreciated so
it can lead some people to just say
false things about the free energy
principle um well just you just made
another statement that I don't I don't
know that it's hinge but it requires
paying careful attention you said
something to the effect of you know the
free energy principle is a theory of all
things but it's not a theory of
everything that's right and and I think
and the way I interpreted you there was
to say that like the free energy
principle applies to all things but it
doesn't necessarily tell you everything
about all things that's right right is
that is that what you meant yeah and um
you know like uh I think that there
there are some states of Affairs uh that
are just not that are not directly free
energy principle adjacent um so I still
don't know why you know the so-called
hard problem of Consciousness right why
does red feel like red why does a Middle
Sea sound like a middle sea but it also
seems to act as a kind of lightning rod
that that attracts you know
multidisciplinary criticism
let's let's say it that that way and in
fact um you know so we we over the
course of kind of studying up on the
free energy principle you know we've
we've read critiques right of the of it
you know so for example um those by Beal
and and others and I'm wondering like
what you think about the criticisms of
it you know do you do you find validity
in them do you find do you find the
quality of the criticisms to be good has
has the FP just moved on from it like
what's what's kind of the
state-ofthe-art if if you will of of
criticism of the of the F Well the first
thing to say is that we appreciate uh
the critical
engagement uh that the free energy
principle has received uh and you know
like any good scientific framework uh it
it stands to benefit from serious uh
adversarial engagement
um uh I think the quality of criticism
varies quite widely in the literature so
to take the uh example of you know Beal
and colleagues uh the I think the paper
you're referring to is a technical
critique of some parts of the free
energy principle yeah uh it it was a
very I think important paper when it
came out uh it pointed out some of the
um
inconsistencies uh in the way that the
free energy principle had been
formalized Circa 2012 2013 or so um and
I mean since then uh the mathematics has
been corrected um and I think we've
moved uh beyond the criticism I I I have
this uh directly from Martin Beal
himself he says you know my my paper the
the the the lesson to draw from this
paper is that you shouldn't in site uh
friston's 2013 paper Life as we know it
to make claims about the free energy
principle which is fair um on the flip
side I would say that we have moved uh
Beyond the formulation as it was as it
stood in
2013 one thing to keep in mind is that
uh so the Fe is sort of like brain
physics or mind physics depending on how
you want to think about it and uh
physics and Mathematics have a strained
relationship uh that I think is
important to think about so um the
history of uh you know developments in
physics often uh goes as follows uh a
physicist U you know borrows some tools
from math itions more or less uh you
know rigorously uh applies the tool to
explain a bunch of interesting phenomena
uh but then that leaves mathematicians
wanting um so for example you know uh
the direct Delta function uh was
introduced in the context of quantum
mechanics U and the the Delta function
is this weird probability function uh
that concentrates all of the probability
mass under one outcome uh so you got
like basically a probability of one for
one outcome and then zero everywhere
else when Dak introduced uh this measure
into the literature statisticians were
not pleased it just didn't seem to them
to be a well- behaved object and it took
a couple of Decades of work in
mathematics and statistics to make sense
of and kind of tame uh you know the
direct measure um and uh yeah you often
get this you can think of a lot of Rec
the history of recent theoretical
physics physics as this kind of back and
forth between like sloppy uh
mathematical physics that gets then
tightened by uh some rigorous
mathematical work and I I think you know
we're in a kind of similar back and
forth here um where you know the FP was
effectively developed as a kind of brain
physics or math physics and uh what we
are witnessing now is an attempt to uh
rederive all of the core theorems in
terms of more well established
mathematics uh and effectively
recapturing all of the core intuitions
uh but within a kind of mathematical
receptacle that uh you know passes the
uh mathematical smell test as it were um
but you know what's interesting too
about uh the the direct Delta function
and and correct me if I'm wrong here but
I think um I don't know if it was the
first but it definitely helped to push
along what later became known as
generalized functions right so so that
spurred some significant you know work
and research in mathematics right oh
absolutely and and the FP is similar in
that you know we're now working out uh
you know some some cool stuff uh having
to do with you know generalized
coordinates um and uh things like
maximum caliber which are which is like
maximum entropy but over paths uh and
all of this investigation is in effect
opened up by the free energy principle
uh and by the can of
worms so so I've never heard I've never
heard of Maximum caliber but let me see
if I can guess what that is so if you
have paths going through you know some
State space I guess it's like the the
you know the uh the crosssection the
cross-sectional area of the paths that
they Traverse or or what it's it's more
like um well it's similar to that but
you're what you're basically doing is uh
you're
considering um the entropy not of
individual states but of entire paths
throughout the system so it's it's
actually the entropy of the whole
path okay and so yeah uh it's an
extension of uh you know James's
principle of Maximum entropy uh but in
such a way that uh we can talk about
like the counterfactual histories of the
system that is like all of the different
paths that it can take through its state
space in in terms of their entropy and
then the principle of Maximum caliber uh
is that the the real path is the one
that maximizes entropy so it's not just
about finding yourself in a in a low
entropy
configuration it's about finding
yourself along a path that ha has the
lowest entropy um yeah and and this uh
turns out to be important um because the
the free energy principle uh evinces all
of these interesting dualities
uh to the space that James is describing
um so in the literature there are
roughly speaking two main families of
application of the free energy principle
uh the so-called density Dynamics
formulation uh and the uh path-based or
path integral formulation um in the
density Dynamics formulation what you're
considering is uh States and how
surprising those states are per se so um
when you or trying to talk about that
what you do is you appeal to this
construct called a generative model um
and the generative model is basically a
joint probability density and what it
describes is the relations of dependence
uh between the variables uh in the flow
or dynamics of a system and so in the uh
density Dynamics formulation uh what
what the surprise is about like I was
saying is how implausible is some
configuration of states of a system um
so this is different from the uh from
the path-based
formulation uh in the path-based
formulation you're considering the
trajectories of system over time and
given the kind of thing that uh you are
for example uh then you're going to have
an inertial path through your system
just given the kind of thing that you
are you know I'm the kind of thing that
wakes up at 6:00 a.m. and has some
coffee and then gets progressively more
tired and then goes to bed at like 9 or
10 and then you know me so
well so if you're that kind of thing
then there is a characteristic or
inertial path that you'll take and in
the path integral formulation the
surprisal scores the deviation from the
inertial path so uh yeah these are
slightly different objects and you can
think about uh dualizing these to an
entropy context where you know in in the
density Dynamics formulation you would
be talking about the entropy of states
or configuration of states or indeed of
the beliefs encoded by those States or
the entropy of entire paths uh so this
caliber
notion um but yeah all of these are kind
of uh joined up and as I'm sure we'll
discuss a bit later uh yeah the uh yeah
the the free energy principle turns out
to be a way of writing down the
principle of uh of Maximum entropy uh
yeah so all these things are really uh
like deeply connected I would say now uh
you know previously I I kind of proded
you about whether or not the physics uh
could explain you know Consciousness and
you said the physicist in you was really
really uh you know leaning towards
hoping it hoping it could so I want to
take this chance while we have you to
ask you about one of our favorite
perennial topics on the show here which
is Emer
you know weak emergence um strong
emergence now um you know there's
there's different ways of looking at it
different definitions of it I think um
what I want to ask you though is that
there are clearly certain behaviors
right that are best modeled and talked
about and described mathematically at
these higher levels of um of abstraction
like thermodynamics okay I mean you know
just there are these bizarre kind of
properties of you know entropy and in uh
temperature and free energy not somewhat
related to the free energy we've been
talking about that you can that you can
develop these equations on right the
first law second law third law
thermodynamics and they apply to these
kind of bulk systems now like uh in
principle in principle and that's really
the the the key word there which is impr
principle if you could write down all
the you know details excruciating
details of every particle and solve you
know wave equations and kind of massive
massive Dimensions you may be able to uh
formulate those laws right and predict
the emergence of those laws but the fact
is nobody ever has like they they they
don't do that we can't do that and and
there's even the possibility that in
mathematics like mathematically these
effective theories right where we you
try to do that you try to write down all
the particles calculate integrals and
averages they can sometimes end up with
these singularities where you can't
cross
you know that divide so I guess my
question to you is is this which is that
and if you couldn't cross the divide
that would be a strongly emergent
phenomenon versus a weekly emerging one
where you could mathematically cross
right so I'm just curious if you think
um first of all if you think there's
such a thing a strongly emergent
phenomenon or if we'll always be able to
cross that mathematical divide if you
will and then secondly even if we could
is there really any point or is it
better just to develop you know
descriptions at different levels and and
just be happy with that at the end of
the day that's a really great insightful
question um I would be inclined to say
that the free energy principle gives you
a kind of heuristic or map to tame weak
emergence um so maybe we we could start
there for a second so the free energy
principle applies in a kind of uh
multiscale manner to uh things composed
of things composed of things and the
kind of key Insight um that you get from
the study of Ensemble Dynamics in the
free energy principle is that um things
can engage in emergent Behavior provided
that they have a shared generative model
so it if if you and I kind of encode the
same dependency
structures then we are going to react in
characteristically coherent ways to
whatever we're experiencing and
therefore we will end up coordinated
even if we're not directly communicating
so the there is a story that you can
tell and I know you've had Mike Levan on
the call here uh on the show here a few
times uh yeah he's he's absolutely
amazing so the this kind of like um yeah
Ensemble behavior that Mike is
interested in explaining has to do with
the emergence of a shared generative
model um so this again uh it's the same
core story you know you have things
interacting over time and that the Fe
says that if there are boundaries in the
system between things then they will
track each other across the boundaries
right so this means that over time
things end up sharing a generative model
and can then begin to display uh
coordinated shared patterns of behavior
um so I think that's really key um the
you know and we we discussed um
Aristotle a bit earlier this is again
removing degrees of freedom from the
parts right if you and I are aligned on
what this or that means it means that
we're aligned on what this or that
doesn't mean so we are you know
coordinating by uh becoming models of
each other becoming good predictors of
each other kind of sparsifying the set
of things that we expect each other to
do and over time we can arve at some
form of like you know coordinated
behavior and I think the the
contention is that this explains you
know biophysical emergence at every
scale where we observe it um so there
there's an argument to be made that
really this is really a theory like a a
formal theory of uh well I mean the the
the Fe itself is not a theory as we
discussed it's a principle but it's a
formal approach to that begins to give
you a grip on how to model nested
systems of systems of systems of systems
uh the cool thing is that the whole
stack operates on the same quantity
basically so you have one objective
function uh it's the same pattern at
every scale it's the marov blanket that
repeats uh and it's this free energy
minimization behavior um you know and uh
so that's I think powerful uh
all you know this segue is one of the
applications of the free energy
principle uh ADV veres is to design um
systems that are able to perform
inference at different scales using the
same uh objective function so the the
variational free energy and if you
introduce this time scale separation
into the mix then uh you know at the
bottom of the stack you have state
inference right so uh I have hypotheses
about what might beus in my data I I am
generating uh data through my actions
and I I end up selecting the hypothesis
that Accords the best uh with the data
that I'm generating but you can do your
parameter learning using exactly the
same uh architecture just on a slower
time scale right so you accumulate
counts of State estimation and then over
time you're able to uh you know estimate
what the best configuration and value of
your parameters are for your model and
then similarly you could do the exact
same exercise at the level of the entire
model's structure and then you know
that's where you get into uh the natural
selection story that the free energy
principle brings to the table I embody a
model in my existence I am kind of
generating evidence for that model good
models persist and leave copies of
themselves bad models are destroyed and
dissipate uh so you you can really tell
a kind of I think powerful multiscale
story uh so yeah I would say like
there's not much that remains in the
weak emergence stuff that you can't you
know address in a tractable manner using
this kind of approach uh your other
question about strong emergence is a bit
more
vexed um you know thinking about this I
think the only thing that might really
be strongly emergent is our conscious
experience um and there are reasons to
think that that actually isn't strongly
emerging but just weekly emergent um in
particular are you familiar with Andy
Clark's notion of basing
qualia
uh not not quite what is it it's very
cool he car he calls this The Meta hard
problem oh okay yeah and what what Andy
is basically saying is that well uh what
we experience is qualitative Sensations
are just further inferences namely
inferences that I am feeling this
right right well that's that's very
similar you know I I really liked um
Professor friston's take on this and I'm
I'm blanking on on the uh on the article
where he described this but but he said
that you know when you when you're doing
this free energy principle and you're
doing this this inference once your once
your inference has reached a sufficient
temporal depth and
counterfactual depth if you will then
that's when Consciousness can emerge
because it can start to model itself and
its own internal States and you know
this sort of thing I think it makes a
lot of sense um absolutely yeah yeah
well you know you're you're preaching to
the choir here obviously I find that
kind of explanation extremely compelling
um yeah and so you know we also have
some interesting in my view uh work on
Consciousness that that we have uh you
know uh in a free energy principle
adjacent uh kind of area been putting
out for you know nearly two decades but
more recently we've been looking at the
question whether you can uh derive a
theory of Consciousness directly from
the free energy
principle um and so we believe that we
can and the idea there is that um
Consciousness corresponds to something
like an inner marov blanket so an inner
screen um so to back up just a little
bit um uh oh uh oh you said inner screen
now people are going to think of the
humulus well so uh that's why I want to
qualify this carefully um you can think
of any marov blanket as a screen of
sorts so it it is um a screen in well
and you mean a screen in like a
mathematical sense yeah exactly like in
the sense of the uh holographic
principle uh in physics right so the
holographic principle is a principle uh
that originated in black hole
thermodynamics and it relates to U our
ability to encode information uh within
a system and what it basically say says
is that you can from from the
perspective of an outside Observer a
given system can only contain as much
observable information as you can fit
onto its boundary um the reason being
that if that if that bulk collapsed into
a black hole U and there were more
information than that uh then you
classical information would be destroyed
in the process yeah exactly and you
would violate basically the principle of
unitarity in quantum mechanics so uh I
you know I mentioned this Quantum
information theoretic formulation of the
free energy principle that I said I
wouldn't get into but it's probably
worth getting into for like two minutes
um so according to this formulation you
can think of the marov blanket as a kind
of holographic screen that separates the
inside of a system from its environment
and it's it's a slightly more kind of
computational take on what we've been
talking about so uh you know the active
and sensory states of the maral blanket
would correspond to uh reading and
writing onto the screen uh or a
measurement and preparation operations
in the kind of quantum mechanics uh
perspective okay so the interesting
thing about the maral blanket in this
formulation is that by definition um
because it is constructed uh or contains
all of the degrees of freedom that a
couple uh you know systems across the
boundary um all of the classical
information that you need to describe
the coupling lives on the boundary in
some
sense so uh Chris Fields about three
years ago along with Mike Levan and Jim
glazbrook uh proposed that well
maybe uh the core architectural feature
of systems that have Consciousness uh is
an internal marov blanket right the the
idea being the the classical information
that I use and bring to bear in parsing
my you know perceptual streams and
deciding how to act has to live
somewhere and so the idea is probably
lives in this kind of internal uh screen
or Markov blanket interestingly uh
there's a way of just taking this stuff
that we were saying about you know
levels in the uh brain and just directly
Translating that into the maral blanket
talk between any two levels of brain
architecture there is a marov blanket by
definition whereby these messages are
being passed so it you can basically
according to the model that we're
proposing so you have an external Marco
blanket right that separates the uh the
internal the inside of the organism from
its outside and then if you look at the
these internal States they have this
structure of a nested hologram in some
sense right where like you have a series
of
screens that are successively coar
graining each other and that are
therefore kind of resonating with each
other and so there's a whole story that
you can tell about yeah the the
emergence of something like uh yeah uh
Consciousness uh just directly from by
appealing to the free energy principle
the kind of key to this architecture is
that at the very top of this nested
hierarchy there is a right only layer
that doesn't get further contextualized
from by anything else right and so
there's a sense in which that layer is
constrained to write down and can only
uh kind of infer itself into existence
vicariously by acting on the other
layers of the network um and so the idea
then is that this is where the uh kind
of um well this is how you resolve the
homunculus Paradox first of all is that
there is a layer that that is not
observing itself it just exists to
observe right layers below um yeah and
so yeah we have a new paper that was
just published it's in a series of two
or three papers that we're articulating
um so I say this because like I think if
if anything is a candidate for strong
emergence the only really serious one is
consciousness and the the the absolutely
utopian over uh confident part of me
thinks that like by uh combining you
know some of the philosophical work that
say Andy Clark has done around basing
qualia with these computational
architectures for conscious systems that
we're developing based on the free
energy principle somewhere in the
vicinity of this if you if you you
know if you look at it for long enough
there'll be something that that'll
emerge to resolve this issue so well
well I guess uh David schors will at
least be happy that um you've identified
Consciousness as the only if there is
something strongly emerging it's only
Consciousness I can't think of anything
else frankly um and I mean
Consciousness May ultimately be
inexplicable uh but it it also may not
and so you know I I'm uh an optimist
until I'm I'm proven wrong uh and we're
going to keep working on this uh I think
you know what we're proposing is just
the the very kind of basics of a sketch
of what a a mechanism for the generation
of Consciousness might look like we're
very very very very far from like a comp
ensive question but uh yeah so um thing
about yeah go ahead well I was say we
weak emergence definitely a cool idea I
think the FP gives you some tools to
handle that strong emergence I I'm not
sure uh like I If if anything is it's
definitely Consciousness uh but maybe
not okay well fair enough and you know I
was going to say what's funny about the
free energy principles it's this onion
that just keeps on giving you can just
keep pulling back more and more layers
and I think we probably have uh I don't
know maybe centuries of mathematics you
know uh inspired by it most
likely well I I mean I I think I think
it is one of the singular most
important
discoveries like uh of the last maybe
200 years like I think you know
the you you've had long discussions with
Carl
so yeah you yeah I mean I I think this
is like you know the this is physics of
mind you know we are we are slow I think
this is the same you know to bring it
back to
mechanics um so
Galileo uh basically
destroyed uh you know it's the Galilean
moment right but like Galileo destroys
thousands of years of philosophy
inherited from the Greeks right the
Greeks thought that there were basically
two kinds of stuff there was the
sublunar stuff and the super lunar stuff
and then the sublunar stuff was governed
according to these four elements where
you know like uh uh things uh that that
that were uh Earth uh F fell down and
things that were fire Rose and stuff
like that right uh and the super lunar
uh was all about like Eternal perfect
cular cyclical circular motions of like
planets and so on right and you know you
can if you were around 400 BC and you
you looked up into the sky it really
would look as if there were two
different kinds of things two utterly
distinct you know the the stuff around
me you know rocks fall to the ground and
uh smoke Rises and and water is cold and
and so on uh and the stuff out there
that just moves in perfect Eternal
Spirals and so on um what what Newton
and Galileo but I mean maybe in
particular uh Newton end up doing is to
say well no actually uh it's all one
kind of stuff uh like it it's it's all
you know subject to the same fundamental
laws it's its classical mechanics and
the Newtonian kind of Galilean Newtonian
moment is sort of like the split where
like you know the old way of thinking
yeah uh started to show uh signs of
being incomplete and a new alternative
arose so kind of unifies all of reality
under the opes of classical mechanics
and I think the same kind of thing is at
play here where you know we used to
think that there was physics and then
there's biology or maybe you know
there's information Theory yeah exactly
or or maybe there's like physics and
biology and then there's the mind but
what the FP is ultimately telling us and
I I you you've heard the this you know
from from Mike and Carl before I'm sure
is that there really isn't a distinction
to make here like it's it's all just you
know physics in some sense and biology
is just slow physics and psychology is
just even slower physics and culture is
just even slower physics and so yeah I
think uh we have the same kind of like
radical Quantum Leap in the way that we
uh you know are able to think about the
world that opens up with the free energy
principle especially when you combine
this to like the philosophy of spareness
and emptiness that I was referring to a
bit earlier like I think what emerges
out out of this is like a real powerful
constellation to to think about the way
that intelligence is expressed in
physical systems and you know that's
also why versus uh has adopted the
approach like here is finally we have
the physics of intelligence so let's
let's build our AI systems on these
bases I mean it it hits exactly thease
phrase that that you said that that so
impactful and meaningful which is the
whole is not greater than the sum of the
parts exactly it's radically less than
the soul some in the park this is
beautiful well listen Maxwell it has
been absolutely a pleasure to have you
on so thank you so much for uh taking
the time to join us and um and talk and
you know I hope you come back on again
seems like there's so much to discuss
I'd love to and you know I I am a
long-standing fan of your podcast So
This was oh thank you so much both uh no
really uh genuinely this was a pleasure
and also an honor uh so thank you very
much for having me um this discussion
was extremely exciting and fun and yeah
let's do this again sometime I i' I'd
love to come back absolutely and best of
luck at versus I'm supportive of what
you're doing there very glad to hear it